when it comes to dating Winona Ryder is  a one-man band the notoriously private  actress tells Neda Porter's the Edit  she's a serial monogamist quote I was  single for a while and dating and I just  didn't know how to do it the 44 year old  was engaged to Johnny Depp in 1990 and  also dated Matt Damon in 1998 before  they split two years later when it comes  to marriage Winona tells the mag I'd  rather never have been married than been  divorced a few times when your parents  are madly in love for 45 years  your standards are really high luckily  Winona seems perfectly happy with her  current beau Scott Mackin lay hon she  has reportedly been in a relationship  with the fashion designer since 2011